We're going to continue with the lecture
on the gospel of John that I talked
about. Uh, last time I started last time.
I want to finish up with some of the
material on John that I didn't get to as
much as I'd like to, and then we're going
to switch to the letters of John First,
second, and third, John, so we're going
to do both of those things. Now remember,
the rubric under which today's lecture
happens is not just the gospel of John
and not just the letters of John
as I've brought up several times.
The method that I'm teaching you right
now in this class is the historical
critical method as it was developed
in the 20th century in Europe,
in North America.
This means that we're not reading these
texts for just what the texts say about
theology or even the early Church or
doctrine or ethics or something like that.
We're trying to read the text in a way
against the very intention of the text.
We're taking the text as being something
like a window that we can look through
to try to construct as best as we can
guess at it. What kind of social context,
what kind of political context,
what kind of church, uh,
what kind of social groups these,
uh,
produced these texts and
found them to be compelling,
found them to be believable. So, um,
there are lots of other ways to read this.
Obviously the gospel of John is very
important for Christian doctrine.
It's the most,
a Christological of the gospels.
It has the highest form of
Christology that is the Christologies,
that's the most divine, uh, rather
than simply being human, human. And uh,
so it's very important for doctrine in,
for theology and for faith.
But what I'm doing right now is
just one particular way of reading,
which is reading this text as a clue,
as a series of clues and traces that we
might use to reconstruct what we think
was going on in the first century
with the growth of Christianity.
And I'm trying to show you by this,
that there are different
kinds of Christianity that
grew up in different places,
different geographical
settings in different times.
So what we call Johanan Christianity is
what we're going to talk about today.
And we're also,
one of the wonderful things about the
John Literature is that by having the
Gospel, which is written, uh, at one
time, and then having first John,
which is a letter written after that time,
we can tell that shows us a development
of this form of Christianity.
And then by having second and third,
John,
which we believe were written
still later than first John,
that gives us a third stage.
So in fact,
what I'm gonna be talking about is three
or four stages in the development of
Johanan Christianity as one branch
of early Christian literature.
So in order to do this,
uh,
I talked last time about how one of the
things going on in the gospel of John is
Jesus.
And the gospel of John Seems to start off
lots of conversations and they lead to
division.
So the causation of division is one
of the themes of the gospel of John.
And to show that we're going to go
walk through a couple of chapters.
First look at chapter three.
This is the story of Nicodemus.
So get your bibles out and follow along
with me because we're going to look at
this in depth.
They were going look at chapter eight
a bit and then we're going to move off.
I said division is the issue.
So what we're going to talk
about is what the division is.
But one of the ways that this author
does this is he sets up Jesus in these
dialogues that don't
actually work very well.
Jesus is not good on interpersonal
communication in the gospel of John.
I'm sorry to have to tell you that and
we'll talk about why that's the case.
So Jesus talks in riddles.
So the question we're gonna have is
why does Jesus talk in riddles and the
gospel of John?
What did he get out of that?
Chapter three
there was a pharisee named Nicodemus,
a leader of the Jews.
He came to Jesus by night and said to him,
now by night, dark, this is
kind of an thematic issue in
the gospel of John, right?
Notice I'm not going to bring
up all these themes this time,
but keep noticing these themes that I
talked about last time as they occur.
Even in this little passage,
rabbi,
we know that you are a teacher who has
come from God and no one else can do
these signs that you do apart from the
presence of God. Jesus answered them.
Very truly,
I tell you,
no one can see the kingdom of God
without being born from above.
How the hell does that follow
from what Nicodemus just said?
He's a key. Gives Jesus a compliment.
You're a teacher from God.
No one else can do these signs that
you do about the presence of God.
Jesus has no one can see the
Kingdom of God. What is there?
Is there? Uh, thank you.
Um,
can Jesus say you're smart?
You just got something there. No,
Jesus starts off changing the subject.
Jesus changes the subject and the
gospel of John Quite a lot. You.
No one can see the Kingdom of God
without being born from above.
Now you're reading it in
English translation might
text just said from above.
Does anybody's translation have something
different there besides from above
without being born a new again,
the problem is the Greek actually can
be translated either being born again or
being born all over again
or being born from above.
The same Greek word means both things.
Now this is the one place
basically in the Bible,
which born again kind
of language comes out.
So it's kind of ironic that there's a
whole branches of American Christianity
which based their entire theology
and ideology on the idea.
Have you been born again? Because
really it's just from this passage.
The other gospels don't
talk about being born again.
It's a rather rare metaphor
in early Christianity.
It comes from this chapter right here
and it comes from a Greek word that could
be just as easily translated,
be born from above as be born again.
So my English translators translated
to decided to translate from above.
But notice it's confusing for the here
because Nicodemus then answers as if he
heard it to be being born again.
So Nicodemus said to him,
how can anyone be born after having grown
old Ken went into a second time into
the mother's womb and be born?
And Jesus said,
Nicodemus, I'm speaking
metaphorically and spiritually here.
You need to understand that I don't
mean particularly that someone has to be
actually born physically
from their mother again.
No, Jesus doesn't say any of that, right?
That's what Jesus should have said.
Probably if Jesus really wanted
to communicate with nicotine buzz,
but apparently,
and John Jesus is not that interested
in communicating very directly with
Nicodemus the cause. Jesus
says, truly, I tell you,
no one can enter the Kingdom of God
without being born of water and spirit.
What the hell does that mean?
Okay,
what is born of the flesh is flesh and
what is born of the spirit is spirit.
Do not be astonished that I said to you,
you must be born from above.
The wind blows where it chooses
and you hear the sound of it,
but you did not know where it
comes from or where it goes.
All right.
What does that mean?
Does it help you to know that
the Greek word translated here?
Spirit is also the Greek word
which can be translated is wind.
So notice the gospel of John
is playing with you with puns.
There's already two puns in this passage.
One does the Greek word,
is it Greek word f being born again
or is it born from above? Well,
you're not told in the text.
In fact,
it sounds like it may
mean a little bit of both.
And is this Greek Word Punch Numa?
Is it supposed to represent the spirit
as a theological term or is this supposed
to represent breath or wind?
It seems to be doing double duty anyway
with all that stuff about wind blowing
where it wills, so it is with
everyone who's born of the spirit.
Nicodemus tries one more time,
said to him,
how can these things be?
In other words, Jesus,
can you give me an explanation
of what you're talking about?
It's not an unreasonable request. Jesus
answered, are you a teacher of Israel?
And yet you don't understand these things.
Well that's helpful.
Truly, I tell you, we speak of what we
know and testified to what we'd seen yet.
You do not receive our testimony if I
had told you about earthly things and you
do not believe how you believe,
I tell you about heavenly things.
No one has ascended into heaven except
the one who descended from heaven,
the son of Man, and just as Moses
lifted up the serpent in the wilderness,
so the son of man must be lifted up
that whoever believes in him may have
eternal life. Well, at this
point, nicotine was just gives up.
We don't hear about nicotine
anymore in the story,
so apparently he's decided I can't
get a straight answer out of this guy.
Yeah,
and notice also how that Jesus starts
off in a dialogical stance with nicotine
buzz,
but never answers his questions.
And then Jesus almost gets kind
of well nasty toward the end.
He kind of just almost insults Nica
demas rather than just explaining what he
means. This is kind of the
way Jesus sometimes talks
in the gospel of John and my
question is going to be why is
Jesus just lacking in social skills?
Look in chapter eight
let's see.
Look at chapter eight verse 31
another little interesting dialogue.
Jesus has been teaching and now Jesus
said to the Jews who had believed in him.
Now notice this scene starts
out often in the gospel of John.
The Jews are talked about as if there's
something other than Jesus is of course,
Jesus is a Jew, his disciples, the
Jews, they're all Jews in this story,
but the term the Jews gets packed in the
gospel of John with this otherness and
this is a reflection of that
sectarianism I talked about last time,
but now notice Jesus is now starting
to talk to the Jews who believe in him.
These are not the Jews who rejected him.
That's very important to see
at this point in the chapter.
These are the Jews who now believe in him.
If you continue in my word,
you are truly my disciples and you will
know the truth and the truth will make
you free.
They answered him.
We are the descendants of Abraham
and have never been slaves to anyone.
Why do you, what do you mean by
saying you will be made free?
And Jesus answered them? Well,
I was speaking metaphorically.
I meant that let's say your slaves
to sin and if you follow me,
then I will make you truly free
in a spiritual sense. I mean,
that's not what Jesus does, right? All
right, 34 Jesus answered them very truly,
I tell you, everyone who
commits San as a slave to sin,
the slave does not have a
permanent place in their household.
The Sun has a place there forever. So if
the son makes you free, you will be free.
Indeed. I know that you
are descendants of Abraham,
yet you look for an opportunity
to kill me. Wait a minute, Jesus.
These are the people who believe in you.
Oh,
because there is no place
for free in you for my word.
I declare what I have seen in the
father's presence. As for you,
you should do what you
have heard from the father.
They had to hand will Abraham is our
father, where Jews, Jesus said to them,
if you were Abraham's children,
you would be doing what Abraham did,
but now you are trying to kill me and
a man who has told you the truth that I
heard from God.
That's not what Abraham did.
You are indeed doing what your father
said. They said him, we are not bastards.
We are not illegitimate children.
We have one father got himself so they
try another tactic. While he won't,
if you won't be satisfied with Abraham,
is the bank with okay,
we'll have God as our father. Jesus
said, if God were your father,
you would love me for I came from God
and now I'm here. I did not come my own,
but he sent me.
Why do you not understand?
What I say is because you cannot accept
my word. You are from your father,
the devil,
the devil.
These are the people who believe in him.
It,
and Jesus ends up the whole
thing is I told, you know, they,
they finally ended up saying, yeah, the
Jews and in verse four days, did you him,
are we not right in saying that
you're a Samaritan and have a demon.
So now they're both being antagonistic.
And finally the, the chapter ends, uh,
way down there as I talked
about last time, uh,
verse 56, your ancestor Abraham
rejoiced that he would see my day.
He saw it was glad. Then the Jews said
to him, you are not yet 50 years old.
Have you seen Abraham? Jesus
said to him, very truly,
I tell you before Abraham was I am.
And there's that strong christological
claim of God be of Jesus being God
himself. And of course, so they
picked up stones to throw at him,
but Jesus hit himself and
went out of the temple.
Notice there these things going on.
Jesus speaks in riddles.
And the gospel of John Jesus does not do
what a good Yale instructor as opposed
to do,
which is explained things to you.
Jesus talks in riddles when
they ask questions, he responds.
And with nonsequitors and then when they
act like they want to believe in him,
he pushes them and then start,
you know,
picking at him and accusing them of stuff.
And eventually the scene ends up
with everybody's all frustrated.
Jesus is accusing them of trying to kill
him and sure enough then they do start
to try to kill him.
And notice how in the gospel of John
repeatedly these issues come down to
Christology.
Who is the person of Jesus?
And the point at which they pick up the
stones to throw at him is when he makes
this claim by quoting exodus,
the very name of God that
Jesus himself is God.
Now with all that going on,
let's look at how this then plays
itself out in the first letter of John
and just to back up,
remember how diverse were
finding Christianity,
and we're going to start seeing that
diversity now represented stuff in
Christology, but we have seen it
already in in geography, right?
We've seen that in the
corn to the book of acts.
The Gospel spread out in
concentrate circles from
Jerusalem to Judea to Samarria
to the ends of the earth.
But we also saw how an acts,
if you read it critically between
the lines, you can see him.
It didn't really spread that way.
They were anonymous Christians who went
off out of Jerusalem after a certain
period of persecution and they took the
message to say weenie and to different
parts of the east of the,
of the Mediterranean. And
these were anonymous people.
We don't know them,
they weren't Peter.
And then later Paul and Barnabas take
things around and Phillip goes off to some
area and maybe there's this Ethiopian
Eunuch in the book of acts who's converted
and he may take the
gospel back to Ethiopia.
So the spread of Christianity historically
was much messier than it really is
portrayed in any straight
forward way in the new testament.
It seemed to have been spread by just
people going to their home villages and
hometowns and taking back this message
that they had heard it different places.
So the, the way the Gospel spreads, the
way Christianity spreads is differently.
We saw for example,
then in Thomas Christianity,
which seems to have been very popular in
Syria and then all the way into India.
That's a form of,
that's a slightly different from the
form of Christianity that's rising up in
Rome in Rome at the time,
and although church tradition says that
Peter was the one who took the Gospel to
Rome and founded the church
there. Well, you have good re.
We have good reasons as you can tell why
we, historians tend to doubt that. Why?
Because we attend, we believe
basically that, again,
anonymous Christians who are lost to
history probably were the first ones to
took the gospel to Rome,
and then Peter became connected
up that to do with tradition.
So there's a certain kind of
Christianity that's growing up in Rome.
There's another kind of, Christianity
is growing up in Syria and India.
There's another kind of Christianity
this growing up in Antioch and and that
part of a western Syria,
and there's another chronic Christianity
we don't know anything about at this
point.
That's probably growing up in Egypt.
We just don't have enough sources to
know what kind of Christianity may have
been growing up in Egypt,
so there's different geographical regions
are experiencing different kinds of
Christianity and those different kinds
of Christianity are diverse with reflect
to the Torah, the Jewish law,
right? If there's another,
if there's still a form of Christianity,
this predominantly Jewish that's located
in Jerusalem and it's led by James,
the brother of Jesus,
who seems to have been famous
for advocating a certain
kind of law, observant,
tore obedient form of
discipleship to Jesus,
then you've got a form of
Jewish Christianity that
still seems to be keeping the
law and we've seen that reflected possibly
in the gospel of Matthew with it's
teaching that the law is still
something that people ought to obey.
We've seen though that the gospel of
mark teaches a Christianity that maybe it
exists.
Some people say markers written in Rome,
other people say maybe with mark
was written in Syria or in Galilee,
but with some kind of Christianity
that is now predominantly gentile,
although it still has Jewish elements,
but these are people who
are not keeping the law.
They seem to believe that they
don't have to keep the Jewish law.
And then we've got the form
of Christianity and Luke
that we saw where the Torah,
the law is not represents a
certain kind of ethnic, um,
an ethnic tradition of the Jews. So if
you're Jewish, you should keep the law.
But if you're a gentile,
you don't need to keep the law.
And then we saw from the Gospel
of Thomas and the gospel of John,
where is the concern about the law at all?
It's not really there.
You can not read all the way
through the gospel of John. Sure.
There's some controversies
about the sabbath,
about what you can do on the sabbath.
But disputes about observation of Jewish
law are not really an issue in the
gospel of Thomas and they're not
really an issue in the gospel of John.
What is at issue in the
gospel of John is Christology.
What do you believe about Jesus?
So let's look at the different kinds
of Christologies you get in early
Christianity too. Before we move on to
the letters first mark the gospel of John.
What is Mark's Christology? What
is his doctrine of Christ? Well,
for one thing, according to
mark, Jesus is the son of God.
Now,
that doesn't necessarily mean yet that
Jesus is completely divine or equal God.
You can be called a son of God without
necessarily being God himself and this
period of Christianity,
but at least mark certainly
considers Jesus the son of God.
He also though considers
Jesus to be the Messiah.
The Christ who has to suffer and use
his suffering is for the purpose of
ransoming us sinners.
So now the Christology that Mark's
working with is Jesus is the Messiah,
the son of God.
He's it's mandated that he suffered.
So it's God's will that
the Messiah suffer.
And that's one of the reasons he writes
his gospel is to convince his readers
that Jesus is suffering and execution
wasn't an accident and it wasn't a
catastrophe and it was a calamity. It
was God's will. It needed to happen.
So the suffering son of God is
part of Cri and Mark's Christology.
If you get to Luke,
as I've said before,
this whole idea that Jesus,
his death was a ransom is not in Luke.
In fact, Luke excises, that part of mark
when he's copying that part of mark,
and he leaves out that ransom passage
from mark because that doesn't fit his
Christology for the, for the Christology
of Luke. Do you remember Luke and acts?
What does the Christology of Luke?
Anybody want to venture of remembrance?
The martyr profit.
Exactly.
Jesus is the martyr prophet who's an
example for Steven or Paul are all of us
who are followers of Jesus
were all martyr profits.
We're called to be martyred profits.
That's not a ransom for many.
So Luke doesn't have a
doctrine of the atonement,
the Christian doctrine that says the
death of Jesus was to pay for the sins of
humanity or to redeem human
beings from the debt of sin.
So that's Luke's the gospel of Thomas.
There's no death at all.
And the gospel of Thomas, the Christology
of the gospel of Thomas Though,
is that Jesus comes across as practically
an already resurrected figure.
He's a knower.
He's a,
he's a figure of wisdom who's come from
the father who had come from above and
he comes to give his
disciples a true knowledge.
So Gilo Jesus as the revealer of hidden
knowledge is the main Christology of the
gospel of John. I mean the gospel
of Thomas. Now the gospel of John,
this is when you get closest to what
will be seen as Orthodox Christianity.
A lot of Orthodox Christology was set,
at least at one of the main
periods at the council of Nicea.
So we call this
the council of Nicea.
In three 25 of our RSCE was a council
called together by the Emperor
Constantine, who was tired of
all these Christian squabbling,
especially about Christology.
And he got bishops and people
from around the empire,
and he tried to get them
to come to an agreement.
They wrote what has come down to
be called the the nice seen creed.
And a lot of Christians, Roman
Catholics, Episcopalians,
Anglicans,
some other churches will actually say
the Nicene creed in church as part of the
liturgy. Right? Can anybody
say it? We believe in,
yeah.
Yeah. Some of you know it. Yes.
You know, the Nice increase,
so that nice and creative
about Jesus being very god
from very God, God from God,
light from light. True. Uh, big, gotten,
not made because that was
one of the Christological
Dee Dee was so was Jesus son
of God because he was born from eternity
is as divine or did God say at one
point, okay, he's a really good guy.
I'm going to graduate him to divinity.
Status was that was one Christology.
So the Nicene creed said,
note Jesus did not become divine.
He always was divine.
So the Orthodox Christology was set to
a great extent by the Nicene creed in
three 25 but how we're,
how do we get from the year
30 when Jesus is crucified,
the or 70 when the Jerusalem temple is
destroyed in the gospel of Mark May have
been published,
the 50s when Paul was writing his letters,
maybe the year in the nineties when
the gospel of John is writing from the,
from those times all the way to the year
three 25 whether it's a whole lot of
fighting going on between Christians
trying to solidify what the Orthodox
Christology should be and all of these
different sources we've talked about.
The one that comes the closest to the
Nicene creed is this Christology of the
gospel of John Because according to John,
Jesus is fully God co
equal with the father.
He's I am.
That is identifying himself
with the figure who appeared
to Moses in the burning
Bush. He's the descending
and ask, sending redeemer.
He's also the lamb of God sacrificed
for the people and in his sacrifice he
takes away the sins of the world.
All of those elements that would end
up becoming Orthodox Christianity,
Orthodox Christology,
those can be found in the gospel of John,
but now how do we get from there to
first? John, any questions about that?
What I want you to really see is I
want you to be able to anchor down,
not just take my word for it,
that will professor Martin knows all
things about all things and he tells me
that there are these different
Christologies and these
different early Christian
documents and so that's what I'm
going to write back on a paper.
I don't want that.
What I want you to do is
be able to actually anchor
down these ideas into these
particular texts that come from
particular different places in early
Christianity.
So any questions about that?
Yes sir.
The Christology of Matthew
is quite a bit like mark.
Matthew also believes that the
death of Jesus, for example, was a,
as a ransom for people
and for sends, uh, uh,
Matthew also that Jesus is the son of
God and that he is the Messiah. Uh,
exactly how divine Jesus is in the
gospel of Matthew is up for grabs.
It's, it's not clear, but he is.
He definitely seemed to believe
that Jesus is divine in some sense.
So Matthew is, Christology is not
too much different from Mark's.
The one thing that makes
him a bit different is that
he seems to also take Jesus
to be something like a new Moses who
either who not is giving a new law,
but it's interpreting the
mosaic law in the proper way.
So Jesus has a law giver and Jesus as a
teacher is also important for Matthew's
Christology.
Any other questions?
Okay. Look at first John,
the first letter of John,
right toward the end of the New Testament.
Yeah.
Now first,
there are several different connections
with First John Two the gospel that you
can see immediately.
So let's hop through the Gospel and see
these first look at the very beginning.
We declare to you what was from
the beginning, what we have heard,
what we have seen with our eyes,
what we have looked at and touched with
our hands concerning the word of life.
That all should sound familiar. There's
the seeing whoa teeth, the hearing motif,
and even the touching thing.
Cause if you remember,
it's in the gospel of John that you have
that famous scene where doubting Thomas
wants to touch Jesus's body to make
sure about that. This is the real Jesus.
This life was revealed and we
have seen it and testify to it.
Testimony and testifying and witnessing
as part of the gospel of John also and
declare to you the eternal life.
Eternal life is one of the themes from
the gospel of John that was with the
father and was revealed to us.
There's Jesus has the revealer.
We declared what we have seen and heard
so that you may also have fellowship
with us and truly our fellowship is with
the father and his son, Jesus Christ.
We are writing these things so
that our joy may be complete,
so we're in the same world,
the same linguistic,
that'll the same discursive, the same
theological world as the gospel of John.
Look at one five this is the message we
have heard from him and proclaim to you
that God is light and in
him there's no darkness. Ah,
that wonderful light darkness motif.
Look at verse seven if we walk in
the light as he himself in the light,
we have fellowship with one
another and the blood of Jesus,
his son cleanses us from all sin.
The blood of Jesus being a
significant there two two 29
if we know that he is righteous,
if you know that he is righteous,
you may be sure that everyone who
does right has been born of him.
So born of him recalls this birth stuff
we've just seen in John Three in other
words,
and there are lots of others,
if you just read through the first letter
of John and you keep your ear attuned
to those themes that you've
already seen in the gospel of John,
you can just underline them and highlight
them all the way through the letter of
John. So they're there. But there are some
interesting problems with this letter.
Also,
look at chapter one verse eight
if we say we have no sin,
we deceive ourselves and the truth
is not in us. If we confess our sins,
he who is faithful and just will forgive
us our sins and cleanse us from all
unrighteousness.
If we say that we have not sinned,
we make him a liar and his word is
not in us. So all of us are sinners.
Yay. You just have to confess your sin
and Jesus lifts in kill. Your is saying,
okay, we're all sinners.
Anybody who says there's not,
you're not centers to the problem.
Look at chapter three verse five
you know that he was revealed to take
away sins and in him there is no sin,
no one who abides in him sins.
Hmm.
I thought we just said,
we're our centers.
No one who sins has either seen
him or know him or known him.
Hmm.
That sounds a little problematic.
Everyone who commits sin
is a child of the devil.
For the devil has been
sitting from the beginning.
The son of God was revealed for this
person to destroy the works of the devil.
Those who have been born of God do not
sin because God's seed abides in them.
They cannot send because
they'd been born of God.
The children of God and the children
of the devil are revealed in this way.
All who do not do what
is right or not from God,
nor those who do not love their brothers
and sisters. Okay? Now wait a minute.
The first part, he says, we all sat
and we have to confess our sins.
This part it says, if you're in
him, you don't sin. And if you do,
send your on the devil.
Look at five 18
we know that those who are
born of God do not sin,
but the one who is born of God protects
them and the evil one does not touch
them. Well, which is it?
Do Christians in John's church
sin or do they not send?
Yeah.
Is there a contradiction here in the text?
That's not the only weird place in this
letter, look at what he says about love.
Chapter two verse five
Chapter Two verse five whoever obeys
his word, truly in this person,
the love of God has reached perfection.
By this we may be sure that we are in him.
Okay,
so love is supposed to be there.
Two 10 [inaudible].
Whoever loves a brother. Now your
English translation may say or sister,
but the Greeks just says brother, and
maybe it's post to include sisters also,
but the gender of the Greek word is
just brother at this point in the Greek,
whoever loves his brother lives in the
light and in such a person there is no
cause for stumbling.
Okay,
so that talks about loving one's
brother. Well, who is the brother?
It seems like the brother for this
writer are other members of the same
community. He's not necessarily
saying what your physical brother,
your blood brother, but he's also not
talking about just any human being.
Notice how this work several times.
So look at two 15 so we're supposed
to love and we're supposed to love our
brothers,
but two 15 do not love the world
or the things in the world.
The love of the father is not in
those who love the world. Okay,
so we're not supposed to love the world.
Love not the world.
Do not love the world.
Remember the world for the word for world.
I'd said last time was cosmos,
the entire universe.
Does this sound a little odd?
If you think back on what may be the
most famous verse in the entire New
Testament,
if you go to football games,
anybody know what the most
famous football verse is?
John Three 16 see it. You know
I'm posters. Did they still?
Maybe they did that years ago. They don't
still do the posters. I guessed right?
Just one guy does it all
over the whole NFL. Okay,
so John Three 16 so yes sir.
Well, I was going to say during
the bcs national championship game,
the Florida quarterback war, John Three
16 on his eye, black. Did they win?
They didn't win any. Made it the number
one Google search during the game.
Great. So the Florida quarterback
war John Three 16 on his cheeks,
these cheeks I suppose. And
um, and that's why they won.
Okay, good. So what is John
Three 16 say? Let's quote it.
For God world.
Y'All are wimpy. For God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son.
For God so loved the world.
First John Two 15 do not love the world.
Hmm?
Yes sir.
I believe so. I actually haven't
checked. Does anybody have a Greek?
Michael has a Greek. Michael is
going to look it up while I continue,
but this is a two 15 and see if a cosmos
or some other word is the word for
world though. We'll get back
to you on that question. Okay,
look at three one see what love the father
has given us that we should be called
children of God and that is what we are.
The reason the world does not know
us is that it did not know him.
Okay,
so love is part of that.
Look at three 11 four this is the message
you have heard from the beginning that
we should love one another.
Okay,
so this is loving one another.
It's not talking.
Hear so much about loving the world.
Look at three 14 we know that we have
passed from death to life because we love
one another.
Whoever does not love abides in deaths.
Three 23 and this is his commandment
that we should believe in the name of his
son,
Jesus Christ and love one another just
as he has commanded us for seven beloved,
let us love one another
because love is from God.
Everyone who loves is born of God
and knows God for 11 a beloved.
Since God loved us so much, we ought
to love not the world, but one another.
Verse 12 no one has ever seen God.
If we love one another,
God lives in us and his
love is perfected in us.
What about the translation?
Yep.
Okay. Same verb, same noun.
And John Three 16 and uh,
John First, John Two 15 so is there a
contradiction? That's just all I'm asking.
Where is the gospel of John Talks
about God loving the world, the cosmos.
And First John says you're not. Christians
are not supposed to love the cosmos.
Contradiction. Mom, we don't
know. Maybe not. Look at four 16
so we have known and believed the
love that God has for us. God is love.
And those who abide in love abide in God
and God abides in them. Keep reading.
Love has indeed been perfected among us
in this that we may have boldness in the
day of judgment because as he is so
are we in this world, in this world,
there is no fear in love,
but perfect love casts out fear for fear
has to do with punishment and whoever
fears has not reached perfection in love.
We love because he first loved us.
Those who say I love God and hate their
brothers and sisters are liars and for
those who do not love a brother,
a sister whom they have not whom they
have seen cannot love God whom they have
not seen the command where
we have from him is this.
Those who love God must
love all of humanity.
What?
No,
I'm lying to you again. Follow
along in your Bible. See,
some of you went to sleep 21 the command,
what we have from him is this.
Those who love God must
love their brothers.
There's nothing in first
John about loving the world,
about loving humanity.
Okay?
About loving Amen.
All humankind or mankind.
There's nothing like that in the
first letter of John. You have,
what you do have in the first
letter of John is that God is love,
but that Christians, the followers
of John must not love the world.
The world doesn't love them. They
don't love the world, does it? Again,
I'm radically sectarian kind of stance.
And in fact,
there's nothing here
about loving outsiders.
According to the first letter of John.
All this love that's talked
about is basically centered
only on the community of
believers. It's an internal
love. It's brotherly love,
but that means that the term
brothers is taken to mean me.
Members of John's own community,
there's nowhere that Christians in first
John are told to love people outside
the community. They're told repeatedly
to love people inside the community. Yes,
sir.
How
to brother? Just to the
community of believers. Well,
you just have to analyze the
letter and see, you know,
how does it occur here and just go through
it. It's occurs all the way through.
Uh, for example, I think you
could definitely proved with
the letters of Paul, uh,
who specifically uses it
for both gentiles and Jews,
but only within the body of Christ.
Whether that's the case here,
you just have to read the letter.
I would argue that it is and as
precisely because I've read the letter as
setting up this dichotomy between the
outside cosmos and the inside brotherhood,
but it's just a matter
of reading the letter.
The word in itself wouldn't necessarily
supply that. Any other questions? Yes sir.
Yes, I believe. Well, sometimes it
fill out. Oh, and sometimes I got paid.
Okay. And the epistles,
it's almost always a guppy.
Any other questions? Okay. The radical,
in other words, what I'm reading in
first, John is it's representing again,
a radical sectarian group.
These are people who see themselves as
a community set apart from the cosmos.
The Cosmos is a,
is a place of darkness and a place of the
devil and that sort of thing. In fact.
And so now it's like what is the
cause of this radical sectarianism?
This is the most interesting problem
of the letter. Look at two 18
children. It is the last hour as you
have heard that antichrist is coming.
So now many antichrist have come.
So there's these antichrist and knows
this is they went out from among us,
but they did not belong to us
for if they had belonged to us,
they would have remained in us.
But by going out,
they made it plain that
none of them belongs to us.
So these are the people he's calling
antichrist or people that used to be
members of his own community and they
left the community for some reason to,
yeah,
so they left that.
Now Look at two 22 who is the liar,
but the one who denies that Jesus
is the Christ. So he's saying,
you must believe that Jesus the Messiah.
That's one thing. Is that the only thing?
Not necessarily.
This is the antichrist,
the one who denies the father and the son.
So some people he's saying have left the
community because they're Christology
is not high enough. They're not
allowing the true son ship of Jesus.
They're not allowing the
messiahship of Jesus. They may be,
you're saying he's just a prophet,
or he's just a human being.
So that's one of the things that's
going on. But look at five one
everyone who believes that Jesus
is the Christ has been born of God.
Everyone who loves the
parent loves the child.
So that's the main part
about Jesus being the Christ.
But now look at for chapter four verse two
I'll start the beginning of chapter four.
Beloved, do not believe every spirit,
but test the spirits to see
whether they are from God.
For many false prophets have
out into the world. By this,
you know the spirit of God.
Every spirit that confesses that Jesus
Christ has come in the flesh is from God.
And every spirit that does not
confess Jesus is not from God.
And this is the spirit of the antichrist.
So one of the things that's going on here,
now look at also five,
eight just briefly, and
we'll move on. Five, eight.
These are three that testify the
spirit and the water and the blood.
And these three agree.
In other words,
this author is objecting to some people
who don't admit the messiahship of
Jesus, and that may have been
reflected also in the gospel. Remember,
some of the reasons that
some of the people there's
this division is because the
writer of the gospel of John believes
that some people aren't willing to confess
that Jesus is divine, that Jesus is
the messiah that he's going to got.
But now we get to a different situation.
Apparently there are other people who
have not come up in the community who may
be accepting that Jesus was the Christ,
but they're denying
that he was fully human.
They're denying that
he was flesh and blood.
And actually we do see different
beginnings of different Christologies.
The people we have a term for this,
uh, these early Christians who said,
they said that Jesus,
maybe there was a human Jesus,
but that's not really the Christ.
The Christ was this spirit that
maybe looked like he was human.
In fact, some said, well, if
he walked along a wet beach,
he wouldn't leave footprints because
he didn't have a physical body.
He just was spirit.
He just seemed to be a body.
He seemed to be flesh and blood
and that the Greek word for seem,
he just looked like we'd get
this term to call dust. SEDEX.
[inaudible] is the Greek word
for to seem or to look like.
So other Christians use this term as a
label for those Christians who said Jesus
wasn't truly flesh and blood, because how
can a divine being be flesh and blood?
That's a contradiction in terms.
You can't have a being that's both God
and flesh and blood because flesh and
blood rots and dies and goes away.
God is eternal.
So God by definition can't be
flesh and blood. And so they said,
if Jesus is divine,
he must not have been flesh and blood.
He must've just seemed like he was flesh
and blood. So other Christians said, oh,
that's wrong. And they call
these people, the seemsters
does sedex.
So docetism refers to a Christology
that says Jesus has spirit,
the Christ, his spirit, but not
really flesh and blood. Human.
And so notice how this author is arguing
against different kinds of ideas and it
shows a further split
in early Christianity.
You have some people believing that
Jesus was human but not fully divine.
Other people believing that he was
so divine that he wasn't even human.
And this author is trying to
hold together these two things,
but now how this happened. So that's
one of, that's what's going on.
The Gospel of the first letter of John
shows a community that's again divided,
but now it's divided by some of the
people within its midst going off because
they thought you can't
have a flesh and blood God.
And therefore if you're going to have
Jesus as God, he can't be flesh and blood.
So they've left the community.
Let's look at second. John,
this is a little time and I'm going to
read all the way through this one cause
this is going to,
we need to sort of figure what's going,
it's a very short letter, the elder.
So he calls himself the elder.
So he doesn't even give us his name,
the elder to the elect lady and her
children whom I love and the truth,
and not only I,
but also all who know the truth
because of the truth that abides in us.
And we'll be with us forever.
Grace, blah, blah, blah.
I was overjoyed to find some of
your children walking in the truth,
just as we have been
commanded by the father.
He's talking to an elect
lady and her children,
most of us think this is a metaphor
that he's actually addressing this to a
church. They elect lady probably
means the church itself,
not a particular human person, but
that's just a judgment. Call my but now,
Dear Lady, I asked you not as though I
were writing to you a new commandment,
but on one we had from the beginning.
Let us love one another.
So there's that love thing. So
we're nowhere. We're nowhere.
It's still in the same kind of
Christianity that we work with the others.
This is love that we walk according to
his commandments. This is the commandment.
As you've heard from the
beginning of this walking,
many deceivers have
gone out into the world.
Those who do not confess that
Jesus Christ has come in the flesh.
There is those people again and he's
such person is the deceiver and the
antichrist be on your guard so that you
do not lose what we have worked for,
but may receive a full reward.
Everyone who does not abide in the
teaching of Christ but goes beyond it does
not have God.
Whoever abides in the teaching has both
the father's son do not receive into the
house or welcome anyone who comes to
you and does not bring this teaching for
two welcome is to participate in
the evil deeds of such a person.
So the main purpose of this very short
letter is to say to another church that's
in the same kind of
community with this one.
There are people who've left our community
and the reason is they don't believe
Jesus was fully flesh and blood.
Don't even let them come to visit you.
These are traveling preachers who
said, he says, don't receive them.
Don't give them money. Don't
give them food. Don't put
them up in your guest room,
just completely shunned them. So he's
riding to another church because of this.
Now look at Third John,
the elder to the beloved Gaius.
Now it's the same person writing,
he says,
but now it's to amending
Gaius not to the elect lady.
I pray that all may go well with you mean
good health, blah, blah, blah, beloved,
you do faithfully whatever
you do for the friends,
even though they are strangers to you,
they have testified to your
life before the church.
You will do well to send them
on in a manner worthy of God,
for they began their journey
for the sake of Christ.
Accepting no support from nonbelievers.
So this is a letter that's been sent
around probably with other traveling
preachers,
but these traveling preachers seem to
be representatives of the elder himself,
the author. So he's writing to a man named
Gaius and says, you, you're a good guy.
You receive our messengers.
You receive the people that
were sending around to preach.
I have written something to the church.
Oh, he did write a letter to the church.
So now let's see what you see.
He wrote another letter to the church.
He's writing this letter to an individual,
but Diotrephes who likes to put
himself first does not acknowledge our
authority. So if I come, in other words,
die entre fees seems to be the leader of
a church and has not allowed the elder
to send his letter to that church.
He's intercepting letters and not allowing
these things to be read aloud in the
church. All these letters were supposed
to be read aloud in churches. You see,
if I come,
I will call attention to what he is doing
and spreading false charges against me
and not content with these charges.
He refuses to welcome the friends and
even prevents those who want to do so and
expelled them from the church.
Diopter fees is refusing to welcome the
messengers from the elder that the elder
sent ahead of himself with the
letter. That makes up second. John,
is he what's going on here?
There's a leader of this Joe hunting
church probably after the writing of the
Gospel, probably after the writing
of first John and he rides second.
John as a sort of introductory
letter to a church and he says,
I'm sending you some of my, My
messengers, you know, received them.
Listen to the letter, give them what
they need, help them out financially,
put them up in your guest room and
then send them on their way so they can
travel around to other Christian churches.
Something's gone wrong though.
Maybe this is a different, maybe third
John, we don't know. This is speculation.
Maybe third John is another letter that
he had to write to an individual in that
town because his second John didn't work.
Why it may be that those people disagreed
with him about his Christology also,
so they may have received the very people
that he thought they shouldn't receive
and so he rides.
Third John Two an individual
saying diopter fees is
causing a bunch of problems,
not receiving my messengers and not
allowing my letters to be read in church.
Do you see how this represents,
this is all guesswork.
We don't know what's going on, but we
see several things about the letter.
There's a greeting,
their well wishes.
There's praise of the reputation
and behavior. The recipients. He is,
he attempts to establish a relationship.
He talks to this person of this.
He's a father,
son or a patron client relationship
and there's a letter of recommendation,
send them on.
This is what you do in the ancient world.
You give a messenger and there's
no post office. You know,
you give a letter to someone
who's traveling and that
person gets to a friend of
yours to where it doesn't
and they show the letter.
That letter is read outside of read
aloud to the group and then you put that
person up or those people up,
you host them for a while,
they talk and you share your
messages and then you send them on.
We give them a little bit of financial
support to send them on their way to the
rest of the travel.
So that's clearly what's going on.
And both of these letters are
letters of recommendation,
typical letters of recommendation.
But what makes it interesting is that
second John seems to have been a letter of
recommendation that didn't work,
maybe.
And then third,
John had to be written to an individual
because his letter couldn't get through
to the whole church.
So what's the cause of this division?
Clearly the cause of division and the
gospel of John is that some people are not
accepting a high enough christology.
They're not accepting that
Jesus is truly divine.
They might be accepting that Jesus
is human, but not that he's divine.
The situation has shifted slightly by
the time we get to the first John the
letter because there it seems like,
yes,
he's talked about some
people are antichrist because
they've denied that Jesus
the Messiah,
but other people are antichrist because
they've denied that Jesus' flesh and he
says they've gone out from among us.
So the church has been split
again on the issue of Christology,
but now the Christology is one.
Do you accept the full flushness of Jesus?
But then when you get
to second John in third,
John the split is the split now doctrinal,
is it Christological or is this just a
split over who gets to be the leader?
Who gets to be the recognized leader
of these church, these churches?
Is it the elder to his letters have
to be accepted in his emissaries,
get accepted in different churches,
or is it this Guy Die Otra fees?
Is he sort of trying to buck the elder
for the leadership and is there dispute
over Christology?
Do they disagree about Christology or is
it now a purely a personnel leadership
issue?
It's very difficult to see,
but you can very quickly see how though
in these by looking at these four
different documents, the gospel of
John First, John Second, John Third,
John Four different documents which
may have been written in this,
not by the same person, we don't think
they're all written by the same person,
but they're clearly written by the
same school of early Christianity.
They share enough of the vocabulary,
enough theology,
and you can almost see four different
stages of development and you see what we
might expect. I remember I said that
and grown up in Texas where I was said,
let's make like a Baptist church and split
early churches also seemed to split a lot.
Is that what we see here,
four different stages of a church with
different kinds of divisions happening
and therefore different kinds of
Christianity developing to do to these
divisions. Very possibly.
Any questions about that?
Questions, comments, outbursts? Now,
what I've just given you is one reading
of these texts and I've done a lot of
speculating. For example, you
could just say, well, second,
John May have been written to one church
and third, John's written to a totally,
completely geographical region.
That's entirely possible.
I think it's interesting to put them
in this way and read them this way,
but that's just one historical
reconstruction because a
lot of what I'm teaching
you is let's,
how do you imagine history developing
if all you have are these texts by which
you construct the history
of the early church.
Next time we're going to
shift gears dramatically
because now we're not going to
be talking about the historical
situation of the text.
We're going to be talking about how do
you get through all these texts to try to
figure out the historical Jesus himself?
Did Jesus of Nazareth Really Exist?
What did he do?
What did he say?
What did he think of himself?
That's what we'll talk about next time.